hey guys it is the ninth of gene today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games foot news but none of
that is quite as important as the fact
that we're at e3 right now it's about
halfway through the day so we've seen
Marcus left and EA showing the spot and
here's what was so damn exciting about
them microsoft made a really big point
of saying that they're showing at e3
this year was going to be all about the
games in fact correct me if I'm wrong
but I'm pretty sure they didn't mention
TV or sports pretty much anywhere during
their conference dismembered limbs
however we're a whole other story we saw
a car door shut for the second year
running on the division and some wicked
witch of 3 action times including an
instance that made me tweet hey girls
bang that chick inappropriate impulsive
tweeting aside let's get stuck into
today's biggest announcements CD Projekt
RED are continuing to deliver on the
gorgeous world of the witcher 3 wild
hunt complete with its lovely gory
combat and chicks the girls may or may
not get with the suave Silver Fox of the
protagonists vaulted his way through the
game well tracking a Griffin which marks
a change for girls usual method of well
traversing our hero got a tad distracted
from his task opting to take out some
bandits which ended with one of the
unlucky brigands getting cut right down
the middle I guess he had to split mmm
sorry about that laura is back in town
and she's ready to raid some tombs and
presumably kick butt in rise of the Tomb
Raider sequel to last year's reboot it's
set to land in the holiday season of
2015 no platform exclusivity has been
announced so it may be a safe bet that
it'll come to all your favorite
platforms at this side of the trailer
Lara is seeing a therapist as well you
should if you spent a significant period
of time being the target of attempted
murder and constantly falling off stuff
like miss Croft as not to mention the
billion assorted reveals whose lives
she's brought to a short shop end you
can catch all the good stuff that
happened including our upcoming mashup
of the conference on gamespot com /e 3
all right let's do EA where Microsoft
stayed away from sports talk EA
delivered its tried and tested line of
obscure franchises and then everything
else as for the former we got classic
lines like let me tell you a story
about the other side of the ball and a
look at a fantasy golf course complete
with a giant warship from a battlefield
4 level yeah it was weird we also got
our first look at Mass Effect and while
that first glimpse of n7 got our hearts
pounding it wasn't really followed up by
much information of substance we got a
lot of conceptual footage on the title
from EA which features a war-torn game
world from a new part of the universe
and we were told yet again that will be
seen totally new characters mirrors edge
2 was much the same story we got
conceptual footage and some commentary
but mostly both segments pulled out all
of the vague they could muster and
basically said it'll be awesome stuff
will look bigger and better and it's
going to be for every gamer just trust
us in awesome battlefield hardline news
not only did we get a huge gameplay
trailer we also got word that a Bader is
opening up on ps4 and PC right now you
can download the closed beta of the cops
and robbers focused installment right
now if you so choose and get in on the
red multiplayer shooty times presumably
with the felling of skyscrapers and
other tall objects inevitably included
because battlefield the game isn't out
until October so if you want to try your
hand at it now and have a copy of
battlefield 4 head to Battlefield
dot-com for info on how to sign up for
what they're suggesting is gonna be a
pretty exclusive beta where Joe Polly
isn't horrendously broken because
battlefield it's waiting for press
conference info drops isn't really your
thing or you're just a huge metal gear
fan you're probably gonna want to know
about the brand new trailer for the
fence and pain that dropped today the
6-minute moody extravaganza took a look
at the characters some of the
environments and what appears to be big
boss smearing ashes on his face the
whole thing is as epic as you'd expect
any metal gear trailer to be at it's
well worth a look let me know what you
thought of marks left and EAS showing so
far today as well as Ubisoft's which
should be wrapping up right about now I
am not wearing a watch in addition to
that tell me your favorite announcements
of the day and the biggest games that
you've got hyped for so far that is it
from me today be sure to let me know
your thoughts on all the conferences so
far answers upcoming and check back to I
III hub at guess what doc on board but
III fro latest and greatest of this see
expert